عيانا ميري جارلاند وزير العدل الامريكي
روبرت هارك مستشاره خاصه لتحقيق في اكتشاف
وثائق سريه في منزل الرئيس الجوبيدن و
مكتب كان يستخدم حين كان نائبا للرئيس في
عهد اداره باراك اوباما وقال جار لاند في
مؤتمر صحفي من المستشار الخاص يتمتعود
بصلاحيه التحقيق مع اي شخص او كيان قد
يكون انتهك القانون في هذه القضيه
في هذه القضيه لن يخضع على المستشار الخاص
من الوزاره
يتلقى جميع الموارد التي يحتاج اليها
للقيام بعمله ويؤكد هذا التعيين للجمهور
للالتزام الوزاره بالاستقماليه
وقال البيت الابيض ان الرئيس الامريكي
سبايدر مان
مع مراجعه وزاره العدل وفي اطاره تلك
العمليه فقد قام فريق المحامين الخاص بي
بمراجعه وثائقي تعود لعمل كنائب للرئيس
وانتهى من ذلك مساء امس واكتشف عدد محدودا
من الوثائق السريه المخزنه في مكتبي
بمنزله وقد تم ذلك ايضا في مركز
وزاره العدل على الفور وقام فريق المحامين
الخاص بي بالتنسيق لتسليم تلك الوثائق الى
وزاره العدل
الامريكيه السابق مرحبا بك سيد بروس فاين
كما تابعنا الرئيس
بوجود هذه الوثائق على ماذا سينصب تحقيق
روبرت هارك
ان القانون المرتبط الذي يجعل من غير
القانوني ان يتم نقل اي وثائق سريه بدون
اي سلطه منافسه مناسبه او موافقه بدون
وبدون عاداتها الى المنشاه المرخص بها
القضيه القانونيه هي ما هي النيه التي
كانت لدى السيد بعيدا عندما تم نقل هذه
الوثائق السريه ووضعها في مكان غير مرخص
وهو في مكتبه في ذلك في هذه الحاله في
الكراج في منزله كان هنالك محاوله لمعرفه
ما الذي كان يفكر به نعرف ان الوثائق كانت
موجوده هناك في حاجته الشخصيه حيازته
الشخصيه لمده سته سنوات هذا هو اساس
التحقيق طيب كيف تتفاعل هذه القضيه او ما
هو الاثر الذي سوف تتركه على الرئيس بيدن
يعتمد على نفسه
اما يستطيع ان يقوم به اذا اراد ان يعطي
ثقدا كامله لدى الشعب الامريكي انه لا
يخفي شيئا هو يريد ان يجب ان يرفع
اربع امتيازات هنالك
ان يتخلى عن هذا الامتياز في مساله
التحقيق في رئيس الحالي وايضا امتياز انه
يخفي التواصل المواصلات عمليات التواصل
بين المسؤولين وايضا امتياز السريه الذي
قد يمنع الحصول او كشف معلومات معينه حول
الوثائق التي قد تكون سريا للغايه والرابع
هو يجب ان يتخلى عن امتيازه حول مساله
وعلى خلاف الرئيس ترامب في همم في تحقيق
هو يجب ان يقول انه
يرضى ان يكون يخضع لاي اسئله قد تطرح عليه
هو يحاول ان يبعد نفسه ويميز نفسه عن
الرئيس ترامب الذي يخضع لتحقيق وفي هذه
الطريقه التي بامكانه ان يتخلى عن هذه
الامتيازات في الوقت الذي نرى فيه ان
الرئيس ترامب يقوم بعكس ذلك شكرا
وزير العدل الامريكي السابق شكرا لك